[Musik]
allein in der wildnis alaskas
das ist die welt von david bittner
möglichen make up ist alles aufbaut ist
passiert ist mit unendlicher dazu
[Musik]
seit zehn jahren verbringt david bittner
fast jeden sommer in dieser
abgeschiedenen gegend
in dieser zeit hatte er mit viel geduld
das vertrauen einiger bären gewonnen
hier lebt der ursus arctos der
nordamerikanische grizzlybär
[Musik]
viele dieser tiere kennt david bittner
von kleinauf er gibt ihnen namen und
kommt ihnen so nah wie kein anderer
[Musik]
david bittner zu hause ist fast
zehntausend kilometer von alaska
entfernt in suhl hier verdient er sein
leben als bereichsleiter fischerei des
kantons aargau mit vorträgen und
fotobüchern kann er seine reisen zu den
grizzlys teilweise finanzieren aber er
träumt schon lange von einem offiziellen
auftrag für einen bären
forschungsprojekt die bären sind für ihn
mehr als ein sujet mit elisabeth pähtz
ihrer familie habe monate gebraucht habe
und eine einzelne
kein taugliches baden dts für mich
chance emotionen sich aus wirklich
verglichen mit familie
weil ich dass
das
also eine familie talkshows
sind kommt das sicher dass denn da
das ist luna ganztag zu zwei minuten
vorm sonnenuntergang und plötzlich die
sonne 42 linien
haben fügte sich alles dunkel und nass
und nachlauf china gewinnt initiiert und
die dynamik und stimmig wenn man daraus
spüre ich sicher
einzigartig
[Musik]
die nächste reise zu den bären steht
kurz bevor
jesse bittner war vor der geburt ihrer
tochter mehrere male mit der arbeit in
alaska
der ruhige art und nimmt angst völlig
einig
das passierte bis mittelbaden nbc -
passiert und ich liebe kennt und weiß
wie nahezu nichts schöneres paket das
die bahn wirklich einfach ruhige die
sind überhaupt nicht wenn man da so
mancher schließt du meinst also der
moment ohnehin muss sagen dass ich das
liebe ich die und vor allem wenn ich
muss vor der leoni verabschiedete sich
das noch nehmen wird
zwei monate wird david bittner
wegbleiben von seiner familie
der abschied fällt ihm schwerer seit
leonie da ist
[Musik]
die reise führt in drei tagen über
anchorage und kodiak an die südküste von
alaska
[Musik]
wie fast jedes jahr fliegt ihn busch
pilot willi führten zu einer einsamen
bucht am nordöstlichsten teil des
amerikanischen kontinents
willkommen in einem neuen zuhause ich
bin gespannt wie es dir hier gehen wird
perfekt ich liebe diesen ort und weißt
du was ich am meisten liebe es gibt hier
keine menschen dafür viele berg
immer wieder bringt folgten abenteurer
in dieser abgelegenen gegend er kennt
die gefahren
ich mag die bären aber ich habe auch
großen respekt vor ihnen ich habe
gesehen was für kräfte sie haben und was
geschehen kann wenn man sie provoziert
[Musik]
jetzt ist david bittner auf sich allein
gestellt
[Musik]
die einzige verbindung zur außenwelt ist
ein satellitentelefon für notfälle
immer schwerer
speziell
wunderschön sagte so macht natürlich
spaß zahlt buchstelle also dass dieses
stück equipment wird plötzlich ganz
wichtig
dass nico
hochrufe
sommer in alaska das bedeutet
höchsttemperaturen von etwa 13 grad und
lange tage die hoar die hoar
stromverbrauch mit der ganzen batterie
und die brauchen für filme und verteilen
und die einzige energie
windows-pcs natürlich nicht wie
erwünscht ist ist natürlich solarstrom
also muss jeder
straße nutzen
der ausgebildete biologe macht sich auf
zu einer stelle wo er in diesem jahr das
spektakel der lachs wanderung
fotografieren will dieses lockt die
bären jeweils in schaan an im fluss
tummeln sich schon hunderte von lachsen
auf dem weg stromaufwärts sie kehren vom
mehr zu ihren geburtsgewicht zurück um
sich fortzupflanzen
david bittner bewegt sich auf den pfaden
der bären ihre wege sind sogar aus der
luft zu erkennen
[Musik]
die krawalle hatten sich in
absolut meisten fasziniert wie es
möglich ist dass das netzwerk
und
jahr für jahr für jahr für jahr treffen
[Musik]
nirgends auf der welt gibt es einen
dichtere bärenpopulation als hier auf
der alle routen halbinsel im süden
alaskas
die bären finden jede menge nahrung auf
kleinstem raum vor allem lachs deshalb
haben sie ein kleineres streifgebiet als
andere berich sie haben gelernt
artgenossen in unmittelbarer umgebung zu
akzeptieren und sind deshalb auch dem
menschen gegenüber toleranter
ok
david bittner besänftigt die bärenmutter
die in anwesenheit ihrer jungen auf der
hut ist
ok
sich unglaublich seiner familie
verzichten
und es geschafft die us vii
viii
sehr internet
eine horde junger
[Musik]
in diesem bach wird sich in wenigen
wochen ein einmaliges naturschauspiel
abspielen dass david bittner auf keinen
fall verpassen auf dem höhepunkt der
laichwanderung werden sich hier tausende
von lachsen aufwärts kämpfen ein
gefundenes fressen für die bären ein
einzigartiges system für den
naturfotografen
doch ist der wasserstand zu tief erst
die für alaska typischen sommerstürme
werden die bäche anschwellen lassen
bittner nutzt die wartezeit um andere
lachse zu fotografieren sie waren der
grund warum der biologe vor vielen
jahren zum ersten mal nach alaska kam
über die laxe erst hat er seine
leidenschaft für die bären entdeckt
ein neuer fernauslöser im ersten test
[Musik]
werden wir dank dass dieser ort besser
aufpassen können sie
[Musik]
nach all den jahren in alaska weiß ich
david bittner zu versorgen in der
wildnis die apple hat miesmuscheln
freigelegt
[Musik]
das ist das minimum ich probiere rückt
um eine große teile vor der natur zehn
jahre es geht nämlich wirklich extrem
viel was das land jetzt
der dank mit einer flasche und zerstach
wie knoblich und triton iii no ist auch
wie man
sieht dass er wunderbar
frischer geht es tatsächlich nicht
unter bären gilt es einfache grundregeln
strikt zu befolgen ich probiere größe
reduzieren alles as the blogs also
gefrierbeutel außer bruchsicher verpackt
um zudem zum elektro tun und kampagnen
zusätzlich noch die ware sichere
container verstaut das ja so ganz
wichtig dass man keine essensreste chris
dreckiges geschirr
ehemalige
[Musik]
kleine nachlässigkeiten können in dieser
gegend tödliche folgen haben
denn auf engem raum leben hier im cut my
nationalpark hunderte von behren wer
sich für das leben der grizzlys in der
wildnis interessiert kommt hierher auch
der amerikanische tierfilme timothy
treadwell verbrachte viele sommer in
alaska ist ein bär ihn und seine
freundin im jahr 2003 tötete ein
schicksal das bewegte und verfilmt wurde
der grizzly man in der wildnis ein
mythos
diesem mythos hat david bittner auch den
besuch eines englischen kameramanns zu
verdanken
inspiriert von der tragischen geschichte
um treadwell will ritter terry den
schweizer bären man für einen englischen
tv-sender porträtieren
terry selber ein riskanter selbstversuch
noch kennt der besucher seinen
protagonisten nicht für die begrüßung
verschwindet der firma schon hinter der
kamera
per bittner nehme ich an
richtig du musst die engländer seien
schön dich zu sehen
[Musik]
pilot willi vierten wird das tödliche
unglück von grizzly man timothy
treadwell nie vergessen er war es der
damals die überreste von treadwell und
seiner freundin entdeckt
da wird es ein ganz anderer typ passt
immer außer dass er wie tim die natur
und die bären liebt aber sie sind
unterschiedliche persönlichkeiten
aller sollte man vor jahren wenn man in
alaska zur haustür raus geht ist man
schon tot klar gibt es hier oben viele
gefahren aber damit muss man klarkommen
ich mache mir keine sorgen um david es
kann viel passieren aber ich gehe lieber
mal davon aus dass ich in heil antreffen
wenn ich zurückkomme
ich zeige dir ein neues zuhause
zu diesem konzept gehört auch der eigene
auftritt vor der kamera
der zaun ist zurzeit nicht unter strom
da ich bereits ziemlich übel riechen
kriegst du ein eigenes zelt hoffentlich
hast du genügend platz für deine
ausrüstung
sind viele wären hier
jetzt nicht es ist ziemlich schönes
wetter und mit dieser brise hat es keine
möglich so hat es dir keinen besseren
tag aussuchen können vielleicht machen
die bären gerade ein nickerchen im
gebüsch und warten bis es kühler wird
wie lästig sind die mieten hier
durch diese preise sind sie verschwunden
sie verstecken sich im kreis aber du
wirst sehen sobald der wind abflaut und
die wolken aufkommen werden sie die
schon noch begrüßen sie werden dich
regelrecht
ich empfehle dir kein
insektenschutzmittel zu gebrauchen das
beste ist sich einfach stechen zu lassen
denn sobald dein körper eine
abwehrreaktion auf du bist lisi biologe
ich vertraue dir
als du ein geschäft verrichten wurst
gehe bitte möglichst weit weg vom crash
und da am schluss verbrennen das papier
ich hasse es wenn ich draußen darauf
stoßen
ganz entspannt wird der besuch der
freiluft roulette für richard eyre nicht
worauf lasse ich mich bloß ein
sich david 1 er hat keine ahnung wie
wenig
ich muss nicht nur einen film drehe über
einen kerl damit begann rumhängt ich
muss noch im zelt leben mit meiner
ganzen ausrüster
diese elektrischen zaun funktionierte
ich zeige dir mal
läuft im moment nicht nach nichts aus
ein dünner draht die batterie hält viele
monate
schreckt er wirklich bären ich versuche
es mal mach ruhig der zaun läuft jetzt
du bist ein video barfuß hättest dich
einige meter zurückgeschleudert
[Gelächter]
roger ives pieper das treibt leute an
dieses leben jahr für jahr auf sich zu
nehmen ich bin bezahlt um einen film
über diesen typen zu machen aber er tut
es freiwillig
david bittner hat seinem besucher
versprochen ihn später zu der stelle zu
führen wo timothy treadwell von einem
bären getötet wurde
es ist zweifellos ein gefährlicher ort
das risiko plötzlich einem bären
gegenüber zu stehen ist groß in diesem
dickicht
viel größer als an einem übersichtlichen
man muss vorsichtig sein und sich
bemerkbar
es braucht ständige konzentration
man kann sich nicht in die sonne legen
und ein buch lesen man muss beobachten
was rundherum passiert
ich meinte einen bären zu hören ganz nah
am lager
sie haben sich verirrt der mutter ist
nach oben
was ist geschehen
wir sind in zelt hatte den zaun nicht
angeschaltet und dann diese zwei jungen
alleine unterwegs neue dürfte
interessante sachen und die sie näher
auskundschaften wollen wenn die mutter
in der nähe gewesen wäre hätte das
gefährlich werden können wir kommen aus
dem zelt raus sie sieht ihre jungen in
gefahr dann hätte sie angreifen können
ernsthaft
[Musik]
auf diese schrecksekunde folgte die
erste nach dem zelt für camping neuling
richard m
[Musik]
ich dachte ich mache es ganz schlau und
schütze mich mit maske und sonnenbrille
aber die mücken konzentrierten sich
einfach auf die fein stellen rund um die
augen
so schlimm wurde ich noch nie gesprochen
was für ein start
als david bittner vor zehn jahren das
erste mal nach alaska kam war er so
unerfahren wie sein gast reuter er will
richard eyre den ort zeigen wo er damals
eine gefährliche begegnung mit einem
bären erlebt hat die sein verhältnis zu
den tieren bis heute prägt
[Musik]
ich fuhr mit meinem kamen durch diesen
bach
plötzlich tauchten drei jungbären direkt
vorne auf
als mich die mutter sah rannte sie auf
mich zu beim rückwärtsgehen stolperte
und fiel ins wasser ich erinnere mich
wie sie ins wasser sprang und hält der
pranke ausholte ich schloss meine augen
schützte den kopf mit den armen und
hatte sie mama easy mann
kurz darauf rannte sie mit den jungen
davon
das war wirklich ein erschütterndes
erlebnis
und dann treffer spray
ich trug ihn die ganze zeit auf mehr
aber ich habe nie daran gedacht ihn zu
gebrauchen es ging alles so schnell
wer weiß was wirklich passiert wenn du
einem bären direkt ins gesichts preist
er
könnte außer sich geordnet ich
attackieren vielleicht geschieht
schlimmer aus als ohne
bewusst wurde dass das - odyssee und es
sehr schlecht die alten meister von
einer unfall zwischen münchen und paare
eigentlich darauf zurückzuführen dass
mehr merken schon selber seine theorie
aber falsch verhalten und das ist eine
bare selber von grund auf so aggressiv
war über den moment hinaus bietet
das haupt die situation und ich alles
falsch gemacht was man falsch machen
ich habe mit passiert nie einen bären
überraschen diese lektion hat der
biologe gelernt
ist er heute in alaska unterwegs macht
er sich immer bemerkbar
der bären forscher zeigt seine besucher
die stelle wo sich die spektakulärste
etappe der lachs wanderung abspielen
wird
das ist immer ein besonderer moment hier
anzukommen
keine bären in sicht aber
im bach hat es noch keine es hat mehrere
sehen es ist einer der wenigen orte an
der küste wo ruth lachse vorkommen der
wertvollste lachs
die bären die menschen
alle fische befinden sich zurzeit noch
im unteren fluss sobald es zu regnen
anfängt explodiert dieser ort und die
fische strömen hinauf zum oberen see sie
kämpfen sich durch all diese steine ein
spektakel
das ist das haupthindernis für die
fische um den oberen see zu
[Musik]
es ist ein tier dem bittner den namen
lou nie gegeben hat die bären ist auf
der suche nach den ersten laxen die sich
zwischen den steinen verstecken sie
sehen die fische nicht sicher sie unter
den steinen
[Musik]
auf dem rückweg ins camp trifft david
bittner auf eine alte bekannte berta
nennt er dieses tier in sichtweite
überlässt er es immer dem bären ob er
näher kommen will oder nicht berta will
sie folgt david bittner
sie sieht gesund aus bereit für den
winterschlaf sie ist nun das günstige
weibchen in dieser gegend neben den
größeren männchen das sagt etwas über
ihren charakter aus berta ist eine
dominante bärin ich vertraue ihm
vollkommen und weiß dass sie mich nicht
angreifen würde auf keinen fall sie ist
einfach großartig
kennst du diesen david ich habe ihn in
den letzten paar tagen beobachtet aber
ich kenne ihn kaum es ist ein sehr
junger bär er fischt noch nicht gut ich
glaube es ist ein männchen aber ich muss
in erster linie sehen damit ich das
sicher weiß es sieht ein bisschen wie
ein fuchs aus
warum gibst du den bären namen
ich finde sie haben einen namen verdient
namen wie jj 3 oder 13 wie sie viele
biologen geben zeugen von zu wenig
respekt
die bären sind individuen zu denen ich
eine art beziehung aufbauen
ich gebe nicht jedem bären
taxi oder fox würde zudem verpassen
warum bedeuten dir die bären sophie
die bären sind für mich der inbegriff
von wildnis
[Applaus]
es taucht ein größerer älterer bär auf
david bittner hat ihm den namen jappy
gegeben er vertreibt den jungbären
[Musik]
das ist jazz fand er hat nur das hören
gewesen das ist erstaunlich der fisch
lebt immer noch
offensichtlich ist das hirn eine den cut
es ist
doch die fische so sehr wie die bären
ist das nicht verschwendung ist es nicht
der nächste bill wird den rest fressen
oder vögel
es ist interessant wie brutal die natur
sein plan will
[Musik]
gott spritzt das wasser vor lauter laxen
der fluss ist voll davon es ist eine
sehr seichte stelle die bären können sie
einfach packen
ich werde mal warten bis sich ein gutes
fotos schießen können
[Musik]
hinter dir hast du den gefilmt
wie die ihren weg finden das ist
verrückt
[Musik]
in
die eier kommen alle raus
kriegst du hunger david
diese älteren fische kannst du nicht
mehr essen ich habe es versucht aber das
fleisch ist nicht gut
das macht auch sinn
die lachse pflanzen sich nur einmal im
leben reiter dann sterben sie die ganze
energie die das fleisch sonst so
reichhaltig macht geht in die produktion
von eiern und sperma darum wird das
fleisch von leichteren praktisch
ungenießbar
also werden wir etwas anderes essen
heute haben es gibt
einen schönen
du wirst ein kajak abenteuer bekommen
zunächst aber steht ein anderer ausflug
an
[Musik]
das ist der tag auf den ich mich am
wenigsten gefreut habe
was denn
du zeigst mir das so genannte grizzly
labyrinth und den ort wo timothy
treadwell sein letztes lager hatte
ich bin nicht sehr glücklich
ich mache das nur dir zuliebe
es ist eine lange reise dorthin zuerst
nehmen wir die kajaks und paddeln aus
dieser bucht dann ziehen wir die kajaks
einen fluss hinauf
von dort geht es lange zu fuß weiter bis
wir zum grizzly labyrinth gelangen dem
ort timothy treadwell starb
es beginnt zu regnen brechen wir besser
auf
oh nein ein bergpfad
danke david
hey wir kommen
[Musik]
der regen hat aufgehört
ach ja ich bin froh schau da ist vor
kurzem ein b durch was passiert wenn
jetzt
das ist ein risiko wenn ich einen bern
bemerkt der sich nicht zurückzieht dann
gebe ich ihm den weg frei
was machst du
dort hallo wer zurufen mache ich eine
kurze pause ich höre genau hin ob ein
bär im gebüsch rasche
alles okay es ist still lasst uns
weitergehen
[Musik]
wir sind fast da
interessiert vor drei jahren waren hier
weil deren pfade und nun ist alles über
wachsen
dort unten ist immer noch der haupttat
aber die kleineren wege sind verwildert
die bären spuren wohl dass hier etwas
spezielles passiert ist das ist der ort
wo tim travel star
dieser kleine hügel mit sicht auf den
gletschern sie
[Musik]
dort unten ist ein großer gut genutzter
bären fahrt er verbindet zwei wichtigen
nahrungsgründen darum ist hier sicher
kein guter ort ein zelt ohne elektrozaun
aufzustellen
ich kann trends leidenschaft für die
bären verstehen aber er gewöhnte sich zu
sehen die tiere
verlor schließlich den respekt
später schien ihm dieser schuss
überflüssig
lange verweilen david bittner und
richard r ii nicht am unglücksort
[Musik]
der große regen hat sich bisher nicht
angekündigt noch immer warten die bären
und david bittner auf den höhepunkt der
lachs wanderung
hey
das ist der schönste
hexe
bittner kennt balu seit vielen jahren
eine magische beziehung
[Musik]
das ist wirklich
dieses fleisch nicht beschrieben dass
koerfer soll nach und nach ab und
der ball fünf meter von mir entfernt
weiß ganz genau dass apple sich egal
ob sie für
die toleranz ist
balu hat seinen fisch erwischt
[Musik]
und auch david bittner macht sich auf
nahrungssuche
was hast du vor
ich will mal etwas anderes zum
nachtessen besorgen ich werde einen
schönen großen fisch im offenen meer
fangen
dieses gewässer ist berühmt für schöne
große heilbutt es geht
[Musik]
der fang dieses riesen fischers vom
kajak aus ist nichts für anfänger
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du willst wirklich von einem krieg aus
einem heim gut fang
wenn ich einen großen fische rische
reicht das für eine ganze woche
schau dir das an das ist unser
abendessen gut gemacht david
das ist unser fisch david
[Applaus]
ich muss ihn zuerst töten
du schneidest in die kehle durch ja man
muss ihn ausbluten lassen
deshalb
so tötet man große fische er blutet nun
aus
er bewegt sich wegen der nerven noch ein
wenig aber er ist tot
es ist harte arbeit einen solchen fisch
im kajak zu fangen er hat eine gute
chance loszukommen die hälfte entwischt
jedes dieser filets wiegt einige von
braun eine woche nahrung für uns beide
und
heilbutt machen müssen als echte
delikatesse
mal schauen was das eher fürs so
gefressen hat ich schneide den magen auf
ich kann es nicht fassen die sind ja
noch ganz ja hat vor kurzem zwei katzen
gefressen das ist eindeutig
mutter kann man nie zuviel verwenden
endlich sieht es nach einem großen sturm
aus
[Musik]
ist das nun worauf du gewartet hast
das ist es jetzt kommt der regen hoher
der wasserstand wird steigen und dann
wird action geben in den bächen zum
ersten mal bin ich wirklich glücklich
über den regen
der zaun ist an
wir sind auf dem weg zum bach es giesst
alles ist gut verpackt es ist zeit zu
sehen was die bären machen
das ist das letzte
wir sind in der nähe des balls
[Applaus]
lasst uns etwas langsamer gehen
hast du das gesehen
ich höre genau hin und schaue mich um
keine aktivität lasst uns weiter gehen
am bach dann die ernüchterung
noch nichts wir müssen noch ein bisschen
warten
keine fische im bach keine bären da
oberhalb des baches raschelt es
plötzlich schau dir das an
doch nie habe ich einen echten bei den
bären gesehen ein bär könnte selbst
einen ausgewachsenen elch polen mit
leichtigkeit haben
wirklich einen elch dieser größe
von großen männchen weiß man dass sie
sogar stiere töten der lz unbehelligt
davon
das warten auf den ganz großen regen
geht weiter inzwischen hat david bittner
einen frischen silber lag sie mehr
gefangen
ich sitze im stärksten regen und esse
frischen silberlack
reis soja soße
[Applaus]
nun schien ihm reden
erst 35 zunehmend sturmwarnung
ein solcher sturm kann in alaska lange
dauern
das glaube ich eher nicht
es ist der zweite tag und die zweite
nacht mit heftigem sturm wenn es noch
lange so weitergeht werde ich verrückt
[Musik]
erst nach zehn tagen ist der spuk vorbei
schau dir das an atoll
alles nass
da ist sie ein see drin ich fass es
nicht scheiße
das war wirklich einer der heftigsten
stürme die ich bisher in alaska lebt
aber in alaska
[Musik]
es tut gut in den ruhigen tag zu legen
nach diesem sturm es ist an der zeit
dass wir uns wieder zum bach auf machen
bevor wir diesen ort verlassen
wir kommen gleich zum bach david wenn es
viele monat muss das wohl ein gutes
zeichen sein jawohl wir sehen sind die
bären meist nicht weit
zumindest die lachse sind endlich da zu
tausenden kämpfen sie sich stromaufwärts
zu ihren laichgründen
[Musik]
deswegen bin ich hier schau dir das
anschaut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind alles rot lachse sie wollen
alle zum oberen see
als fisch biologe erlebe ich das mit
gemischten gefühlen einerseits ist es
unglaublich beeindruckend andererseits
ein drama wahrscheinlich bringen sich
die meisten fische selbst um die bären
können sie einfach packen
david hinter dir
okay die bären kommen es wird zeit dass
ich mich davon mache ich bin praktisch
mitten in ihren frühchen
[Musik]
im herbst nehmen die bären drei bis vier
kilo pro tag zu sie wiegen dann fast
doppelt so viel wie im frühling ohne
dickes fettpolster ist der harte winter
nicht zu überleben
[Musik]
es ist ein unbeschreibliches gefühl so
nahe bei diesen tieren zu sein
[Musik]
die vorboten des winters sind an der
küste angekommen die nächte sind frostig
und die tage kürzer es ist zeit
aufzubrechen
ich werde diesen bach vermissen das
tosen die fische die bären und die geben
aber ich freue mich jetzt auf meine
familie zu hause
wenn jemand vorbeikäme und david und
mich mit all diesen preisliste er würde
meinen wir sind total verrückt aber die
wahrheit ist die bären gehen äußerst
friedlich miteinander um und auch mit
uns wir befanden uns nie in gefahr
hallo david du hast überlebt wie war es
gut
ich bin froh dass ich heil anzutreffen
david bittner reist heim in die
zivilisation aber er wird zurückkommen
nach alaska zu seinem bären